the military has been drafted into
picking up covet 19 bodies
that succumb to the virus at home
it's their third one this morning and
they take no
chances as they are called to the home
of an 84 year old woman
her last rights are hurriedly performed
by the family
there is little time for mourning and
almost none
for rituals in this deeply religious
hindu community
at one of the largest government
hospitals the conditions are telling
a makeshift center outside as everything
inside the building
is in short supply attached to oxygen
they wait their turn to get a look
inside
doctors and nurses doing their rounds
and monitoring critical levels
patients have come from across the
country as public health facilities in
rural nepal
is woefully inadequate
74 year old bahadur took a six-hour
grueling journey
to find the hospital full the family
has decided to head back to the village
inside they are jostling for space
for some even the floor will do as long
as it's inside
sky news was given access to the
hospital's icu
a month ago there were just 150 daily
cases
now the country reports 8 000
and the second wave has been lethal and
[Music]
relentlessly
each passing day the death rate is
mounting
a month ago the daily average was seven
deaths
it's now almost 200 a day
fear of infections families are not
allowed inside
and grieve from outside the gates
watching and praying from afar
aid agencies have warned the country is
running out of vaccines
the government has appealed for
emergency supplies
as more than a million wait for this
second shot
less than two percent of the population
are fully vaccinated
the pandemic is spreading across the
valleys and mountains of nepal
with more than half a million cases this
impoverished nation
is now grappling to keep its people
alive
neville lazarus sky news